merrill kelly is on the mound for
arizona with a 7-10 record fastball
curveball cutter change-up for merrell
throws a lot of strikes attacks the zone
70 strikes with his fastball 70 strikes
with two strikes runners in court
scoring position
so he gets after does not walk a lot of
guys so a rough start here a walk in a
two-base set to open tonight's game so
here's ozzy albee's banged in the air to
deep left field this will send peralta
to the wall he squares up to it and
makes the catch just shy of the warning
track
that'll send solaire to the plate
sacrifice fly rbi number 98 for ozzie
and it's one nothing braves in the first
he's good by ozzy certainly would have
liked to have gotten a base hit there
but
spoiled some good pitches
kept himself alive and inevitably had a
productive out one-nothing braves here
in the top of the first inning first and
third one out now the batteries duval
and duvall smashes one deep to left
center
and adam duvall
has done it again just beyond the reach
of mccarthy
nobody knows who's got it does jake have
it he does not it's in the seats adam
duvall was pointing that out
he passed the runner yeah riley stopped
going to second base and sam holbrook
the crew chief down there might be
throwing him out and in the top of the
first inning for the braves three runs
and one what in the world just happened
he has had a tough time in the first
inning no question about that 6 55 era
in the first inning this season 309 era
and all other innings so be important
for him to get off to a good start
that's cool calhoun in right field
tonight batting cleanup lead at first by
marta and that's a fair ball down the
line martay's on the move it's in the
corner rosario out there to fish it out
here comes cattell cole calhoun has an
rbi double nice job of getting by cole
so another run in the first inning for
ian anderson this one comes with two
outs nice piece of hitting right there
got a four seamer
down and away
cole calhoun just kind of goes with the
pitch shoots it down that left field
line
well you know gonzo since he's come back
he looked like he never left yeah he's
had some great at-bats we saw that in
the series against houston yeah and he's
doing it again here against the atlanta
braves rodney five for ten in the series
with five rbis and young man you're in
range
yeah you are i have to move back though
swinging a drive got the arms extended
deep left center on cue austin riley
hits a home run
number 31. koji needed to move back deep
to left center and way out of here and
no doubter and it's his second home run
in his many nights
rbi number 95 for austin riley
and it's a 4-1 lead for the braves so
atlanta gets that home run back and it
is now a 4-1 lead yeah that pretty swing
again there ball was in but a little bit
up
and austin able to get his hands
extended on it
and that ball went a long way tell you
what braves are peppering the concourse
aren't they yeah they are
having a hard hat on if you're gonna sit
out there man oh man
those six straight batters have been
retired by anderson arizona has two hits
a double and a single calhoun has the
doubles swung on and missed strike three
and it gets him with a change up and
that's strikeout number five
so seven up seven down for anderson
who's in a nice rhythm got him swinging
strike three and it's the change-up that
takes care of peralta who's now over
eight in this series
ozzy albies delivered a sac fly in the
first inning his 98th rbi as ozzie
cracks that one down the right field
line did he keep it fair yes he did
6-1 atlanta and ozzie has his 30th home
run of the year
and he's got 100 rbis
enjoy that trot mr hobbies
[Applause]
how's he looking in that three spot yeah
that's that's fitting in perfectly don't
you know he loves getting to 100 with a
home run
what a season
mattel marte has walked and scored and
he's taken a call third strike another
shot at ozzy one hopper easier play
throws him out boy an easy inning for
ian there
three up and three down he's retired 14
in a row ian anderson has set a career
high now he's retired 14 consecutive
batters
so far one walk eight strikeouts he's
given up only the two hits yeah he's
really controlled the strike zone and
really his best pitch tonight has been
that change up he's had those d back
hitters off balance all night long a
little chopper
big hop
and a laser to first to get marshall 15
straight
arizona hitters have been retired
one down for cole calhoun in the air to
deep left center field sprinting over
adam duvall trying to run it down he
does
great catch by adam duvall out in center
field
he was going over towards that column in
left center with a 413 marking and was
able to run it down great wheels for
adam this is a young man authoring a
masterpiece round ball into the shift in
shallow right there's austin fires over
to freddie you can't do any better than
ian anderson he's retired seven teams
straight
so chris martin is back to work how
about the braves bullpen in september a
270 era
that's good to hear
you know the bullpens are going to be
used down the stretch and in postseason
play these guys as a group peaking at
the right time yeah they sure are i mean
they've had their you know ups and downs
at times during the course of this
season but uh certainly appear to be
um on the upside right now swinging a
drive hit to left did it pretty well
rosario back and this one's gone home
run
only the second of the year here at
chase field for walker his ninth home
run of the year the diebacks have closed
the gap a little bit it's six to two
christian really got a hold of that one
108 miles an hour off the bat
just a line shot
that was loud off the bat got a fastball
in the zone and that time gonzo he
barreled it up
he did just a nice swing loud pop off
the bat he knows he's got it when he hit
it
just off the glove of the fan look out
back to the top of the order to jorge
solaire here's the 1-1
in the air to deeper right going back
calhoun
he's under it makes the catch tagging at
third contreras here comes the throw it
goes to second and they hold there also
tagging jack peterson he goes second to
third it's a sack fly for jorge soleil
he drives in the run and it's now seven
of two braves here in the night graves
get that run back that they gave up in
the bottom of the eighth inning and
here's freddy who has two base hits both
doubles two runs scored no rbis for
preview tonight ripped in the air to
deep right center field i'd say he just
won the battle
that ball might take a bath that one
just took the plunge out in right center
and the raids increased their lead it's
now nine to two atlanta two outs bottom
of the ninth runner goes fly ball to
left field right in line with eddie
rosario and he squeezes it and the
braves have won four in a row
they win the night 9-2 ian anderson was
as good as we have seen him since last
year
[Applause]